les stylos viennent d'être posée le
temps est écoulé les élèves de cp de
l'école de base ont passé leur
évaluation de français chapron château
afin qu'elles maîtrisaient des moyens
devient trop deux épreuves de français
de mathématiques au programme de cette
deuxième session d'évaluation mise en
place par le ministère
ils ont un petit livre est là pour les
évaluations me cpl sont répartis en
quatre séquences de séquences de
français de séquences de mathématiques
et puis ils ont des petits exercices
alors son trait guidée avec des repères
la rectrice
en visite ce jour là vient faire un
point d'étape sur le déroulement de ces
évaluations
c'est très précieux d'avoir ce temps des
changes avec vous tous on a vu ce matin
la classe de cp qui venait de passer la
deuxième session de français donc ça
veut dire qu'ils ont déjà fait la
première session et la première session
de menthe aussi des évaluations
critiquée notamment par certains
syndicats et enseignants qu'ils y
trouvaient notamment trop longue
la deuxième session est plus courte de
façon à ce que ça ne prenne pas trop de
temps aux enfants et puis surtout on a
on a bien réexpliquer la nécessité de
bien respecter les conditions de
passation puisque l'objectif c'est que
en fassent un point précis de ou en et
chaque enfant de façon à pouvoir les
aider chacun individuellement
en attendant les élèves de l'école de
bunge ont encore une évaluation de
mathématiques à passer